- [Instructor] We are
told b of one is equal
to negative seven, and b of n is equal
to b of n minus one plus
12, and they're asking us
to find the fourth term in the sequence.
So what we have up here,
which you could use a function definition,
it's really defining
the terms of a sequence.
Especially if are to input
whole numbers in here,
it's the index on your sequence.
What we really wanna do
is, we wanna figure out
what is b of four going to be equal to?
Well if we just blindly apply this,
we would say all right b of four,
so be of n, is equal to
b of n minus one plus 12,
so it's gonna be b of
four minus one plus 12.
Well four minus one is just three,
so it's going to be equal
to b of three plus 12.
All I did is said okay, well
we're not trying to figure out,
or we're not immediately
trying to figure out
what b of one is.
We're trying to figure
out what b of four is,
so n is equal to four, so b
of four is going to be equal
to b of four minus one,
or b of three, plus 12.
To evaluate this, we have to
figure out what b of three is,
so let's write that down.
That's what's fun about
a recursive definition.
You have to keep recursing
backwards, so b of three.
Well if n is three, that's
going to be equal to b of,
now n minus one is two, b of two plus 12.
We don't know what b of two
is, so let's keep going.
We need to figure out b of two.
If we use the same definition,
b of two is going to be equal
to b of two minus one plus
12, so b of two minus one.
That's b of one plus 12, but
we don't know what b of one is,
so let's figure that out.
B of one is equal to, well
here we can finally use
this top clause, so b of one
is equal to negative seven.
Now we can go and fill everything back in.
If b of one is equal to negative
seven, then we know that
this right over here is negative seven,
and now we can figure out
that b of two is equal
to negative seven plus 12
which is equal to five.
If b of two is equal to
five, well then this is equal
to five right over here,
and then now we know
that b of three is equal to five plus 12
which is equal to 17.
If we know that b of three is equal to 17,
then we're ready to calculate
what b of four is going to be.
B of four is now, it's b of three,
which we figured out was 17 plus 12
which is equal to 29,
and we are done.